[Music]
[Applause]
Tom pellicero kind enough to join us on
loan from NFL Network and uh where do
you want to start what team do you want
to start with
I feel like this has been TV right now
is me trying to remember 27 different
names in every hit and remember who's
interviewing with who what the schedule
is on everything it's it's a fun time of
year and this process is going to be
longer than any we've seen just because
of how they've kind of legislated it
with some of the updates to the Rooney
Rule and the way that they want these
things now uh to flow I I think that one
of the interesting ones is is in Denver
right now Jim Harbaugh interviewed
yesterday virtually for over two hours
with the Broncos the Broncos uh you know
their search committee by the way is
really interesting because it's Greg
Penner who's now the the basically the
head of the Broncos but also Condoleezza
Rice is in on the interviews of course
some of the football people are are in
on it as well but Harbaugh have to put
out that statement last week saying uh
he expects to enthusiastically be
coaching Michigan in 2023
continues to explore his options he's
one of the top candidates there so is
Sean Payton who is obviously the the
issue of working out compensation with
the Saints they can't interview Sean
until I believe it's a week from today
uh and then of course they're they've
also put out slips for guys like the
Miko Ryan's and Rahim Morris who are
going to be and Dan Quinn who are going
to be top candidates elsewhere you know
somebody's got to come in with a plan
not just to fix Russell Wilson but
really a path forward for that
organization and since you know we're
talking about Walmart money here uh
there will be no cost spared in
procuring the right head coach they're
going to be very aggressive with this
I'm trying to understand what Harbaugh
is doing it it was reported that he was
seeking out a meeting with Caroline and
David Tepper
I did he do the same to Denver or did
Denver reach out to Jim Harbaugh
no Jim Harbaugh was very much on the the
Broncos radar so he coached before he
was with the 49ers he was at Stanford
Condoleezza Rice has deep ties to
Stanford Greg Penner got his MBA there
so they know a lot of the same people in
the same circles and so as they were
coming in and evaluating what to do
really since the sale closed back in
August that was always a name uh that
was going to be on their radar so this
is very much driven by the Broncos new
ownership group they're the ones who are
going to be making this decision they
obviously showed in firing Nathaniel
Hackett with two games left in his first
season that they are not afraid to move
swiftly uh on these things and so the
plan was always to swing big and that's
where Jim Harbaugh Sean Payton Dan Quinn
unless everything falls through I'd be
surprised if one of those three is does
not end up ultimately being the Broncos
head coach but if Harbaugh plans on
being at Michigan why doesn't he just
say to Denver thank you but I don't have
any interest
there's one thing Jim Harbaugh has not
done in his um you know illustrious NFL
career both you know as a player who
started a lot of games for different
teams and then as a coach you know he
took the 49ers the three NFC title games
and one Super Bowl lost to his brother
in that Super Bowl you know he's 59
years old the Super Bowl is something
that he's always chased he likes the
idea of it I think he also can't
Overlook the Dynamics in Michigan you
know he's now in I believe it's his
eighth year there back coming off the
covid season they gave him a deep pay
cut he was I don't know exactly where he
stacked up but he was not one of the
higher paid coaches in power five uh got
a raise after last year when he made a
run and then now you know Michigan could
step up and give him the type of
Lifetime sort of contract that keeps him
in Ann Arbor forever to this point
they've not finalized anything along
that front I'm not saying that's what's
driving him is the financial aspect of
this but you know he would like a
commitment and there is an Allure to the
NFL
um you know I'm sure some people I see
them in my Twitter mentions complaining
that this is all leverage and you know
the same people also are are stressed
out because what's he doing to his
recruiting class and everything else Jim
Harbaugh is a unique individual he's a
unbelievably successful football coach
and so as long as Jim Harbaugh is
willing to entertain the NFL the NFL
will always entertain Jim Harbaugh how
surprised were you what Arizona did
yesterday
not surprised because Michael Bidwell
the owner had been uh moving like a guy
who was going to run a coaching search
he had been doing homework on candidates
he had been talking to various people
about how he would set up a search
process because remember his sounding
board for the past decade or so has been
Steve Keim the general manager took a
leave of absence a month or so ago and
then now it was announced formally which
is always the expectation that he will
not return to the team so that was his
football liaison uh Bidwell needs help
to run this process so he was seeking
that out that made pretty clear that
Cliff Kingsbury's days in all likelihood
were numbered here Cliff will be just
fine he just signed that extension back
in I want to say it was around March
through 2027. so he'll make plenty of
money to leave and now Michael Bidwell
has to hire a new GM he wants to do that
first and have that person
um lead the charge for the new head
coach
what about the Colts
don't count out Jeff Saturday that is
the one thing for all the uncertainty
about what direction this goes and the
full plan with the Colts is to cast a
wide net they're going to talk to a lot
of people they put out I believe 400 of
your requests yesterday for see if I can
do this Ben Johnson Aaron Glenn from The
Lions Shane steichen and Jonathan Gannon
I think that's the right I think that's
the right list I might mess one up
anyway they put out a few of them but
they're going to take their time they're
going to continue to do interviews here
but Jim irsay is a big fan of Jeff
Saturday he believes in Him despite a
one in seven record as the interim coach
seven consecutive losses you've seen
Jeff Saturday certainly
deflecting the blame for lesser for lack
of a better term in talking about how he
would do things differently and he
believes in different things we don't
know what those things are because he
has no track record to lean on but
basically he said hey I can't fix
everything at this time so give me the
opportunity that would start with the
offense he'd need to hire a strong
offensive coordinator Jim Harbaugh is a
big fan of his he likes him a lot he
wants him to have a fair shake so until
told otherwise consider Jeff Saturday a
serious candidate in Indianapolis do we
have updates on Tua and Lamar
this weekend
two uh we'll know a lot more tomorrow if
he's able to do anything on the field if
he's not because he still has multiple
steps left in the concussion protocol
then that would mean he's not going to
be able to go this weekend and his
backup quarterback Teddy Bridgewater
remember dislocated his pinky in week 17
he can throw the ball I've been told
that's why he was able to address this
past weekend as the backup quarterback
but obviously they didn't feel
comfortable enough with him going out
there that's why they started Skylar
Thompson so it's not just Tua it's also
can Teddy do enough through the course
of this week the bills right now have to
prepare for I guess three different
quarterbacks but again if Tua doesn't
get out there on the field tomorrow
there won't be enough time for him to
progress and quite frankly just in
talking to various people I'd be
surprised it's not impossible but I'd be
surprised if we see Tua and then in
terms of Lamar Jackson it's really in
the same place that it's been for the
past several weeks here when he
initially got hurt the Hope was he'd be
back in probably two to three weeks from
that PCL injury it's now been five weeks
going on six we've not seen in practice
he's missed 15 consecutive practices
five games we have not heard from Lamar
um you know obviously you never want to
you know cast doubt on how injured
anyone is I would just say it's a
surprise that he's been out as long as
he has and so you know the answer is
while Lamar has told people that he
believes he can play and while there's
optimism from the Ravens they truly
don't know who's going to be the
starting quarterback this week and then
also there's questions about new puntly
because he couldn't play last week and
he ended up with a a rookie undrafted
player in Anthony Brown having to start
a a really important game that by virtue
of the Ravens losing it means that this
game this weekend is back in Cincinnati
Tom pellicero NFL Network Insider uh got
an update on Demar Hamlin
I know that he's back and now in Buffalo
leaving uh the Cincinnati hospital he's
back he's at Buffalo General hospital
now continuing his rehab I mean
unbelievable Ben if you go pack a week
ago I don't think any of us as we're
watching listen I've covered the NFL for
20 years
that was probably the most terrifying
thing I've seen in 20 years you know
just in in the past decade or so if you
want to talk about the the scariest
looking injuries it was Ryan Shazier
breaking his neck it was Tua suffering
that concussion back in week four and
then it was DeMar Hamlin collapsing and
going into cardiac arrest all three of
those events by the way happened in
Cincinnati which is strange they all
ended up in the same hospital
um just a bizarre coincidence there
um but you know the fact that you could
go from that and you know the NFL stops
for nothing it stopped last Monday night
for Demar Hamlin uh that shows you how
significant this was and so the fact
that he's progressed to now he's walking
around he did a lap around the hospital
he's doing physical therapy he's
FaceTiming with his teammates he was
able to travel back to Buffalo he's
still got a lot of steps left I mean
this is something that the doctors that
at the University of Cincinnati Health
Center said it was going to be measured
in weeks and months it's not like you
know three days from now he'll be you
know doing normal things but he has
progressed better than anybody could
have expected here and um I think that
we're all thankful for that just as fans
of fans of football and um human beings
who witnessed something really horrible
that it certainly seems like is going to
end up with the best possible outcome
Sean McVeigh is sort of taking inventory
of the TV World here
um
he's taking taking stock of a lot of
things if you watched that press
conference yesterday Dan I mean he he
sounds to me and I don't want to play
amateur psychologist here but just in
listening to his words he sounds like a
guy who knows he's burned out
knows that he needs a break and is
struggling to cope with what that means
for his life and if he's doing the right
thing because once you walk out the door
even though the Rams would certainly
hold that door open from him you're in a
different place in your life I mean I
would compare it to you know for me if
after 20 years of covering the league
and doing news every day something I
just want you know what I'm burned out I
feel burned out all the time if I just
keep going because what else am I going
to do with my life if suddenly you just
shut that down and you don't have that
constant 24 7 Perpetual thing that keeps
you going or you you know leaving Sports
Center like I can't imagine that was a
an easy thing to do when something that
so deeply defines you and that you put
all your life's work into and now you're
saying I don't know that I want to do it
right now it just seems like he's really
grappling with that he also said he's
not done coaching so you know is that a
Sean Payton Bruce Aryan style break here
where he takes a year away and then he
comes back if so do the Rams even run a
coaching search or do they name let's
say Raheem Morris is the interim coach
and then say if you want to come back in
2024 you can you know all those options
I think are are possibly on the table
here just because Sean's one of the most
talented football coaches we've ever
seen but he's got a lot that he's got to
figure out here I know he said he
doesn't want to drag it out the coaches
got the indication yesterday would
probably be by the end of this week
we'll see whether or not he's willing to
or ready to make a decision at that
point but this is not something we see
very often here 36 years old you know at
the top of his game less than a year ago
winning the Super Bowl and now talking
very openly and candidly about he might
need a breather here
do the Bears have their quarterback
considering they have the number one
overall pick
it's a great question and something that
they have to evaluate there's a lot of
things that they like that they've seen
out of Justin fields and to be fair to
Justin Fields it's not like he was
throwing to a top receiver group this
year you know they did make the trade
for Chase Claypool he got hurt almost
immediately and it's really hard to
integrate receivers mid-stream and other
than that you know nothing against the
other guys he's throwing to but you know
Darnell Mooney's a really good solid
player but is he a true one who's going
to carry that team economius St Brown
has fought his way for everything he can
run but you know is he a really true
number two they've got to upgrade that
they got over 100 million dollars in cap
space they're going to put weapons
around him uh there's enough to build
with there but it does bring them to an
interesting uh Crossroads here you know
it's kind of like what we were talking
about last year when Howie Roseman made
the trade with New Orleans picked up an
extra first round pick in this year's
draft at the time it was well if Jalen
hurts isn't the guy then he's got two
first-round picks he potentially could
move up you could draft a quarterback
high now Dylan churches put himself in
the MVP conversation and so it would be
a big surprise if the Eagles do not
ultimately commit to him as their
long-term quarterback but you know the
Bears have to sort that out do they feel
like there's a generational Talent
whether it's Bryce young or will love us
or somebody else I'm sure they're going
to go through all those evaluations I've
heard nothing to indicate that they're
going to move on at this point from
Justin fields and if they're not that
also puts Ryan polls in a power position
here because this is not the 2022 draft
where nobody was taking a quarterback
number one nobody was taking a
quarterback in the top ten you've got
multiple quarterbacks in this draft who
people potentially can convince
themselves are worthy of the number one
pick and so polls already has amassed
draft picks from some of the trades they
made they've got all this cap space and
he may be able to turn that number one
pick into a lot going into the future
here as well always great stuff Tom
thank you thanks for joining us thanks
for having me that's Tom pellicero NFL
Network Insider